jour j dans coûte
merci d'être en direct ce matin dans la
matinale rt france pour nous parler de
la crise ukrainienne à vue d'israël le
pays qui est qui scrute de près ce qui
se passe parce que le il serait là aussi
des intérêts en ukraine est également en
russie
voilà
partageait ce qui explique la politique
très très vigilante vis à vis le des
côtes est donc vous a parlé de la visite
de la vie s'est mise à part étrangère en
israël et il faut dire que le veni après
un incident plutôt incident diplomatique
entre le ministre des affaires
étrangères israélien mais c'est la pid
et l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en israël et
qui à reprocher remercié l'appui des
cons
qu'on parle trop et on commet avec avec
le russe et qui seraient les vrais quand
même et pensez aussi à l'ukraine et à
cause des intérêts communs et il a
comparé et cette situation à celle qui
est fait
instaurée et quand il y aurait eu la
guerre en europe israël restera celle
est vis-à-vis de l'iran il faut dire
qu'il faut dire qu'ils y seraient comme
l'a redit à des intérêts des deux côtés
il ya des grandes communautés juives et
des deux côtés il ya beaucoup
d'israéliens qui vivent en ukraine et
vous montrer donc ses vols d'évacuation
qui serait là initial il faut dire que
ils sont pas très très utilisée il ya
certains qui sont partis de lestrem mais
il y a beaucoup d'autres qui sont restés
beaucoup plus il ya de dizaines de
milliers
d'israéliens sur place une communauté de
quelque
mille personnes
juives qui ne l'est pas il ya un très
forte communauté se place donc israël
doit jongler entre le 2 et
ce matin a dit
ce n'est pas qu'on n'a pas une politique
mais il faut qu'on soit vigilant
équilibré ce qui démontre les problèmes
et serait rien à ce qui les concerne les
propositions de la ministre bis ministre
des affaires étrangères dans sa visite
et une chaise était récemment à qui m
comme tout le monde d'ailleurs en
attendant quelque chose qui n'arrive pas
qui ne se passe pas et je parlais à
cette occasion vice ministres la vice
premier ministre madame à stepan et
china
d'espoir contente de la collaboration
entre israël les frères el habib et
qu'il y a quand même une collaboration
et coopération et au sujet au moins ils
ne changent et 10 dead expertise aussi
j'ai par exemple de la berri bray deux
de l'organisation de la remettre cetera
les présidents du parlement ukrainien et
le président du parlement ukrainien
monsieur stéphane fouks et m'a dit qu'il
est très très contente des relations
avec israël il faut qu israël et demande
qu'on craignait rade et continue à
démontrer son appui
justement on entendu la vice ministre
des affaires étrangères dit c'est dans
le besoin qu'on reconnaît ses vrais amis
et ça sonnait en pot commun en un ultime
at home
cell même s'il a quand même quelques
propos et quelques propos intéressants
concernant l'intérêt israélien ça veut
dire l importation
des produits craignent un périphérique
l'année par l'ukraine en l'occurrence ce
sont des armes oui bien sûr mais
qui veut démontrer
l'utilité pour israël des relations ai
dit qu'ils seraient là même elle dépend
des
produits de base craignant et que
d'autre part il y à rien et entrée
rue c'est dans la mer noire et avec
force et en syrie il y a un lien direct
entre les des dombes et de points de vue
et de points de vue stratégique aussi
mais ça ce sont bien sûr les excuses et
les motivations les arguments l'ukraine
est un peu
en demandant disons une
collaboration plus forte est ce que je
vais dire qu'israël ne peut pas se
permettre ce que l'api inconnu
collaboration beaucoup plus prononcée
et les partager entre et
elle a des relations avec le député
d'arrière et la liste d'avis finissent
affaires étrangères et à demander et à
israël et d'essayer d'aider un peu
l'intermédiaire entre les beautés suite
aux intérêts qu'ils seraient là dans le
dépôt tm et c'est vrai que les exigences
au niveau sécuritaire
on comprend et on connaît bien le aussi
la la la la volonté d'israël de protéger
ses frontières est ce que est ce que
vous comprenez aussi celle celle de la
russie de de vouloir protéger ses
frontières
il serait quand même comme si l appui de
essaye de comprendre les des côtes et
espère bien sûr qu'il y aura pas de
guerre
dans la région qui ne sera pas bonne
elle
donc qu israël ne suis pas non plus
toutes les déclarations bellicistes des
états unis
il faut dire
a
dit qu'est ce qui a étonné vers le bas
selon ses informations
pour l'instant tout se passe normalement
il n'ya pas qu'il n'ya pas un danger
immédiat de guerre et ce qu'il a
est-ce que vous avez démontré et
quelqu'un qu'elle quelques pas de et
geste est quand même de précaution et il
faut le dire il faut le dire
aujourd'hui
la guerre
là-haut l'acteur independent d'un d'un
geste et d'un geste qui peut être un
geste irréfléchi et parce que en
principe est en principe quand je vous
ai dit j'étais là c'est ma cinquième
personne et 3 pas la bière il ya
beaucoup de journalistes cubains qui
essaye de trouver de chercher et des
signes annonciateurs d'une guerre
il reste là et elles sont très étonné et
les ukrainiens n'y croit pas et donc de
ce point de vue c'est une situation très
très bizarre très bizarre où la bière
guerre semble imposer de façon
complètement illogique et de ce point de
vue c'est vrai qu'elle se sent surtout
les les déclarations de précision
américain une fois la guerre va éclater
demeure qui est qui et qui titrait cette
situation mais d'autre part il ya bien
sûr aussi la concentration
et de l'armée russe qui sont sans
précédent et donc c est ce que c'est et
tactiques
américaines et bien d'une précaution et
ce qui sûr ce qui sûr qu'il s'agit ici
d'une guerre de propagande de contre
propagande et il faut je pense son
analyse et sa et dans ces termes là et
pas pour l'instant et heureusement dans
des termes physiques sur le terrain
parce que personne ne veut voir et qui
va gagner de cette guerre
merci beaucoup en tout cas merci pour
votre analyse gideon coûte dans la
matinale et arte france ce matin